c'est faux merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors ce rapport dit
clairement que les droits fondamentaux
des détenus radicaliser ne seraient pas
respectées
oui bonjour effectivement la cgmp elle
est une fois encore dans son rôle
elle privilégie l'idéologie qui est la
sienne
doté d hôte peut véhiculer l'ufap unsa
justice
alors dire de les droits fondamentaux ne
sont pas respectés je demande à voir
peut-être est-il juste un peu ses héros
où il s'est effectivement voit si on est
d'accord sur l'aspect des droits
fondamentaux
ça veut dire qu'on est pas d'accord avec
ce rapport c'est pas con débarras
correction c'est qu'on a pas c'est qu'on
n'a pas attendu la cgn bn unis pour
notre organisation syndicale pour être
critique à l'égard des unités dédiées de
ce qui s'est fait de 2015 seulement on
n'est pas dans une idéologie ou nés dans
un contexte très réaliste c'est dans une
des propositions très pragmatique vous
savez nous on a remis en 2018 un petit
livret qui a été validé par département
justice de la commission européenne sur
la prise en charge des détenus est
aujourd'hui laissent ils restés lettre
morte
michele nos dirigeants ligue
d'administration il ya un moment donné
oui effectivement la loi est la raison
c'est que la prise en charge est
totalement inefficace et les inefficace
parce qu'on ne veut pas aller jusqu'au
bout du raisonnement et il faut
reprendre également l'historique de ces
quartiers
ils ont été mis en place après les
attentats 2015 dans les conditions qu'on
sait mais il faut aussi garder en
mémoire que la directrice de
l'administration pénitentiaire de
l'époque
la garde des sceaux de l'époque était
aussi totalement opposés à ce genre de
chose puisque l'expérience
fresnes qui avaient des mises en place
elles fin 2014 devait normalement ne pas
être prolongés et ne pas être non plus
généraliser
malheureusement le contexte terroristes
et l'attaquent de 2015 a fait que les
choses ont dû évoluer et bouger au
niveau de l'administration pénitentiaire
et on a mis en place des quartiers pour
dire voilà aujourd'hui on fait quelque
chose et on pourra nous reprocher
d'avoir rien c'est donc effectivement en
termes d'efficacité c'est la seule chose
qu'on va partager avec la cglpl
aujourd'hui c'est de dire que oui ces
quartiers sont totalement inefficaces
ça va tu menais d'accord donc des cartes
et inefficace vous êtes d'accord sur ça
avec le cglpl mais le cglpl dit
clairement ce n'est pas efficace certes
mais que les conditions de détention de
ces prisonniers est très précaires les
conditions des tensions oui mais c'est
le sens du rapport oui enfin bon ça
c'est sur ce terrain là si j'avais pu
être d'être maintenant dire que derrière
les conditions de détention sont loin
d'être favorables pour les détenus a
rappelé que dans les maisons d'arrêt
dans un contexte habituel la crise
sanitaire
on avait un taux de surpopulation qui
était énorme aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
avec les terroristes ou radicalise et
que vous vous retrouvez dans un quartier
d'évaluation de la radicalisation dans
un quartier prise en charge de la
radicalisation
vous êtes seul en cellule alors ça c'est
une première chose derrière vous avez
accès à des activités que les autres
détenus n'ont pas donc ça c'est une
seconde chose et ensuite derrière ça
reste de la détention ordinaire c'est un
régime de détention ordinaire s'est pas
beaucoup moins régime d'exception c'est
pareil j -pd isolement il sait pas
régime disciplinaire
donc nous dire qu'aujourd'hui les droits
fondamentaux de ces détenus là sont pas
respectées on en discute sérieusement et
au terme de
conditions de détention il faut aussi
qu'on en parle parce que là si
effectivement on parle des conditions de
détention il faudrait peut-être
aujourd'hui garder en mémoire que le
détenu qui lui dénie et en guise me
radicaliser
il ya des conditions des tensions
maintenant que ces gens là bas le cpl
déjà rappelé également que les
conditions de détention en prison en
france en tout cas était précaire par
seulement les les détenus radicaliser la
fée le le point de son rapport mais plus
généralement l'a déjà fait sur d'autres
prisonniers en tout cas je voudrais
revenir à des gouttes justement on parle
de là précisément de prisonniers
radicalisé mais il ya un autre problème
soulevé c'est les critères pris en
compte pour l'intégration de ces
personnes détenues au sein de la
catégorie 10 des personnes radicaliser
sur quoi se basent sont concrètement
pour dire qu'un prisonnier un détenu est
radicalisée ou pas et donc bénéficient
de ces quartiers qui ont été créés il ya
cinq ans disons que j'ai la même
interrogation où c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les critères que diniz
administration pénitentiaire doit
essayer des chiliens ce qu'un des plus
radicalisés reste aussi floue
aujourd'hui en 2020 que ça l'était y
attend quand on a été confronté pour la
première fois dans l'administration
pénitentiaire à ce genre de phénomène
c'est à dire que les choses n'ont pas
évolué une époque et qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'une personne radicaliser nom revient
toujours à la question des bas c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où mais pas
des mouches sur les les mines et des
problèmes on ne peut pas résoudre ces
problèmes
c'est dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
arrêter d'empoigner le mou radicalisé
mais employer le mot sa miss et islam
politique l'a effectivement une fois
qu'on aura désigné le problème on pourra
et essayer ou une solution monsieur fond
vous venez d'ouvrir un autre débat mais
c'est la fin de cette interview merci
dit avoir répondu d'avoir est en direct
avec no mercy